the media stuff is so shocking to me
because i you know i worked at cnn for
years and i posted a couple shows there
several shows there and then i you know
i was the main anchor in msnbc for four
years i got fired
but you know i i still have a really
good friend who will remain nameless who
works there just a wonderful person
really good guy and i have a couple of
friends at cnn so
not a ton too but uh but anyway but i
know that world really really well
and the biggest surprise for me in one
sentence is how ill liberal they are i
always imagine they're liberal networks
no no i'm liberal okay in the sense that
like i believe in the enlightenment and
i i believe in the bill of rights and i
think we do have rights um
they are not liberals they are defenders
of the powerful which is the much graver
sin like you can have silly politics i
get it i've had silly politics maybe i
do now people make mistakes
but defending the billionaire class
blaming everything on like working-class
white people who are like you know
by far
the most shafted people in america look
at the suicide rate look at the death
rate i mean it's like it's measurable
but everything's their fault
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host of tucker carlson tonight on
fox news and the author of the new book
the long slide 30 years in american
journalism tucker carlson welcome back
to the reuben report ladies and
gentlemen thanks for having me dave
tucker you are not in your studio you're
not in a suit you appear to be in some
sort of secret bunker area with books
and pictures what's going on over there
i'm in i'm in my barn actually to be
totally honest which is where i work i
live in a rural area in northern new
england and we have an old barn that we
use for
everything basically to store the boats
and
my wife has her peloton and we have our
studio in it and you know bunk beds for
people and so yeah i live in my barn
so you're kind of living the dream that
you always wanted in a way i mean a
couple years ago i've quoted this many
times quoted you actually many times you
walked into my house opened the door to
my garage and i don't know if fox news
is going to want me to say the exact
thing you said but you basically said
holy effin [ __ ]
you've done it meaning that i had a
studio at home and i was able to run my
operation you you've kind of expanded
into that world while still maintaining
the mainstream cred
what yeah i mean
i have to say
i've always believed that what matters
is how you live you know what's your
what's your life like what do you do
when you wake up what time do you wake
up who do you wake up with i mean those
are the things that define your life
and so when i saw how you lived i
thought man
this guy is really i mean i know people
who make a ton of money
who don't live anywhere near as well as
you do and i was just so impressed by
that and um of confluence of events
happened and what i mean we actually
live in the town that we've been in our
whole lives so it's not we didn't move
anywhere weird we this is where you know
we had a house here always growing up
but
um why not just move there and so we did
and it's been wonderful
yeah and you were dealing with some
headaches living in some other places
because you know obviously the media
matters people and all the usual trolls
and everything they were sending people
to your house and right you know going
out i mean literally like going after
your wife and kids and all that i know
it's not fun to talk about that but can
you just talk about it a little bit just
sort of relative to you're just trying
to do what you think is right as a as a
journalist and as a personality and then
how it affects the the life and the
people around you yeah i mean it was
just sad to see it happen i moved to
washington as a kid my dad worked for
the federal government and um on the
cold war and doing pretty honorable
things i would say i think that anyway
and um so i've lived in washington
essentially my whole adult life i mean
since high school
and it's a bipartisan town i mean by
definition both parties are represented
both parties live there and as a result
there's been this permanent truce
effectively for decades where you can
live next to people you disagree with
but you don't talk about it at dinner
parties you can be friends anyway and i
love that environment a lot of my
friends had politics different from mine
and then
in 2016 trump was such a threat they
were so worried not that trump would
actually do anything any and he really
didn't as as
as we know
but he said stuff and he said obvious
stuff and they were so terrified that
trump was going to point out some really
obvious things about the way things
actually work that they were
completely threatened by i mean really
threatened by it was like a foreign
power occupying the city and the hatred
the bitterness
and i just kind of agreed with a lot of
trump's i don't know ideas may be a
little strong but themes
you know like when you run the
government you should always ask
yourself is this helping the people who
live here who voted for me who pay for
all of this whose country it is
i really agree with that i always have
so um
that the division in the city between
the overwhelming majority of people who
saw trump as this satanic figure and the
tiny minority of us who were like well
yeah okay trump
whatever it's obvi you know he's got all
these personal faults got it but he's
making really good points
like what is the point of nato for let
me just pick one of a thousand examples
why shouldn't we have a border wall you
know what about all those people who
died of fentanyl like what's the answer
and all of a sudden it just became
impossible to live there and then
you know i've never lived behind a gate
or anything we lived right on the street
in the city all that raised my kids my
four kids there and all of our dogs and
all this stuff and i felt like we were
really part of the city and then
next thing you know people are showing
up at the house and you can sort of see
where this is going you know it's so
threatening
you know where does it end you're going
to end up shooting somebody and i don't
want to do that you know i hate but
that's that's where it's going you know
because just living there was so
provocative to them
having them show up and threaten
violence against my family was so
threatening to me
that it just it wasn't going to end well
and i just thought
and our fourth child went off to
boarding school
and we didn't have any kids at home and
so we're like well wait you know why
don't we just move to where we already
spent the summer so we did
yeah so do you think that the people
that you're talking about there that are
sort of the permanent dc class and the
swamp as trump would call them do you
think it's a conscious decision that
they're always existing to keep
themselves in that power or is it just
that you just get there and then before
you know it you're just in this thing
and and you like what's happening so you
just stay in that thing so that's why he
was the threat to it and i would argue
that in a weird way you now that trump
has stepped away a lot of the hatred
that was just always directed towards
trump is now directed more towards you
because you're carrying the torch for
some of those ideas yeah i mean i'm not
totally aware of that i i have a kind of
peripheral sense that i'm disliked by
some people but you know i don't i don't
have a television i don't i don't go on
the internet i don't use social media
i'm pretty i'm pretty insulated from
that stuff because
literally you literally don't i know you
don't check twitter but you literally
don't have a television
oh no i've never had it i've never had a
tv no
no no i just didn't you know i didn't
grow up like that and my dad worked in
tv when i was a kid and he was
he was pretty pro reading i would say he
was a militant reading person so yeah we
had a lot of enforced reading in our
house and so yeah that's how i grew up
but um
yeah but mostly you know i i have a very
close circle of friends and i have a big
family and i'm really close to my wife
and my producers who i absolutely love
my executive producer i'm really close
to them so i have a lot of people around
me
who will tell me the truth and do
um if they think i'm being a douche or
i'm crossing some line or whatever
they'll just say it i mean they're not
afraid they're not afraid of me at all
so unfortunately um so i
i feel like i've got a pretty good
series of backstops against going
totally crazy
and so and i really care about their
opinion because these are people i love
and respect and so my view has always
been my whole life
you know i had a weird childhood which
kind of changed my view on this but but
fundamentally was you should only care
about the opinions of people who care
about you
and who have you know demonstrated
loyalty and wisdom and an ongoing
relationship why would you ever let
strangers
have control of your emotional state
like that's insane and you know you hear
people say that but i think i'm in the
rare category of people who mean it so i
would never go online and like google
myself why would i do that
no i i know you mean it
right exactly i i know you mean it
because i think the first time we met in
person i asked you something about the
hate and the twitter mentions and you're
like i don't have twitter like it's you
you know it's tucker carlson on twitter
we're like it's not you know i'm not the
one checking it and tweeting this stuff
and that keeps you kind of insulated and
safe and sane it's yeah and and i have a
huge number of people i talk to every
day i mean i spend my whole life talking
to people mostly by text but hundreds of
people and i try to clear my text every
night it was up until two in the morning
in front of the fire where i live it's
cold
um on september 1st and uh with my dogs
you know and i'm up really late banging
out these texts taking notes so i i i
speak to a ton of people and not just
people in my world not just famous rich
people but like a lot of random people
a waitress that i had in big sur and i
hope she's watching this i know she's a
fan of yours
years ago
has
i gave her my text for some reason she
and her husband are like such thoughtful
people and she has been texting me ever
since and i swear once a month two
nights ago i used one of her lines on
the air
like at least once a month i'll like run
with the story ideas she sends me so i
have a huge number of people that i
correspond with
but i don't want to open it up to the
mob i mean i because then i can't think
clearly and my whole job is
you know and i don't always pull it off
but i really try to think clearly like
what is going on here you know ascend a
little bit get higher look down
what are the outlines of this and being
involved in this [ __ ] you [ __ ] you too
you know
i don't like noise in my personal life
i like quiet and i don't like noise in
my work or intellectual life you know i
like to i like to think i like nature
you know i like i like hunting and
fishing i like to be outside
i don't want to sit in a room and read
other people's hysteria i don't think
there's any upside to that at all trust
me man as a guy that just spent 30 days
in a rainforest basically i completely
feel that and i've realized that my my
relationship with social media has to be
a little bit different and one of the
last things that i remember before
leaving in july was that you sort of got
accosted while you were going fishing
basically by this by some guy and what
was so interesting about it and i say
this about everything these days it's
not the incident itself it's not the
incident it's the way the media reacts
to the incident so this guy's kind of
getting in your face and the way the
whole media was like yeah yeah well
tucker's mean so everyone should get in
his face and be more mean about it's
like man that will lead us all to a very
dark place well someone's going to get
shot i mean
i'm serious i mean like where do you
think that ends you yeah you
physically confront people because you
don't like their opinions about politics
in front of their children i mean one of
my kids was there i was in a fly shop
that i've gone to for you know many many
years
in a town that i've gone to for many
years and that i really love
and i it gosh it felt i mean this is so
whiny and i try never to whine
in public or private but oh wow it
really felt like a violation and i
thought well like you know i'm never
going here again
which was sad
but then you know there are other places
to go i guess um i live in a really
beautiful place with just
i mean untold miles of
empty rivers and streams and lakes and
like why am i in montana anyway
um
stay in maine you know but but anyway
just made me sad and but i also think
it's very unwise to do that i lived in
dc for 35 years i would see people all
the time i i disagreed with you know
i've had dinner with nancy pelosi i
stood next to barney frank i remember it
at an event i i could you know that was
my whole life yeah and the idea of
screaming at someone because that person
disagrees with me was like insane and
this is what happens when you have a
secular society at scale which has never
happened in human history there's always
this there's always a religion because
people have a need for meaning you take
that away and people just replace it
with political ideology and that's what
it's really about the guy screaming at
me felt that i was an apostate you know
i was attacking the one true faith or
something that's not how i see it
but it's how a lot of people do see it
and i
and i think that we should be aware
that the end point of this is violence
like that's where it's going you know
what i mean and i hate that i hate
violence i've seen it a lot actually i'm
totally opposed to it but the way that
the things have been set up the way we
communicate the end point is violence
and i just i say that all the time on
the air
because i think people should know that
let's pull back a little bit
yeah which is so interesting because
then the way they'll frame it is that
you're throwing these firebombs and it's
actually the reverse it's a warning but
to your point on the on the secularism
part do you see where we're at right now
as just sort of the end of a purely
sort of secular america that at the end
of uh at the end of just a secular
america two plus two now equals five
boys or girls we don't know which way is
up our history is no longer our history
that sort of without
some sort of undergirding of religion or
some some subset of belief that this is
what you get and and i really fear this
because as you know as someone that
considered myself liberal my whole life
i i wanted that thing to work but i have
come to the uncomfortable truth that it
cannot work it simply cannot work when
it's purely secular you know you're
always going to have a religion and you
know you you can say well the
crucifixion is kind of a ridiculous
story the talmud is sort of absurd okay
but compared to what
right what do you got that's better yeah
compared to the idea that men can get
pregnant or two plus two equals five
like it's you know you're you're trading
one superstition for another
and
that's just the state of man like we're
always going to have a belief in the
transcendent because we're wired that
way and but you need to think carefully
about what god you worship what you know
what religion you sign up for here and i
think we but we should be honest about
it i mean the political discourse that i
just described that you live in the
middle of every single day
is not about convincing people it's not
rational people bringing you know a set
of facts to the conversation to try to
persuade the other side to join them of
course not it's a religious work that's
exactly what it is so we should just we
should name it this is it called the
mask stuff
you know i i won't be boring about it
but in one sentence like we spent a year
first of all i was really worried about
covet at the beginning i think we're the
first show on cable tv to note that
covet existed because you know
interested in the rest of the world
saw this in central china what is this i
thought i believe the numbers it's going
to be you know three four five percent
mortality really you know many millions
would die
so it's not a question of not taking
covet seriously if you take it seriously
you want
solutions that are effective i mean
that's that's how you give
the virus the respect it deserves
is by responding to it rationally and
the mass stuff in particular things
about vaccines too but the mask stuff is
so totally unmoored
from any kind of research data at all in
fact there's a lot of countervailing
data that shows it's kind of productive
and bad
we keep saying this for like a year
we're like well no there's this new
study out of vietnam the biggest unmask
ever done and everyone's like oh yeah
shut up mass desire
and i finally realized because i'm i'm
not super smart that like they don't
care what the evidence there's no
interest whatsoever masks are good this
is what we know this is the catechism
and i'm like okay
this isn't public health this is
theology
so i don't really know what you do with
theology that's why we don't talk about
it like when you know i'm a wasp so when
i was a kid it was like no you don't
talk about religion in in a public
setting because it's it's too personal
right sex religion politics off-limits
so i just don't really have the tools to
argue
with people over religion because my
default setting is
you know hey everyone has their beliefs
like leave i'm very liberal that way
the problem is theirs is an evangelical
religion
you know it's 7th century islam it's
convert or die it's really really
aggressive whoa
so what do we what do we do with that i
mean i've spent a lot of time when i was
off the grid thinking about just that
because i'm with you that we sort of are
in a cold civil war in that and i don't
want a civil war obviously i don't want
violence just as you laid out and i want
this thing to work but it seems to me
you have a set of people that i would
include people like us and which is
basically live and let live and we can
talk about where the government should
be right but then we but then we have
this other set that want everything and
they want everything from us and to tell
us how to do everything though that's
not a liberal arguing with a
conservative that's something much more
dangerous because they are not going to
stop so so what do we do with that those
of us that want to live freely
you know i don't i don't know um i've
been like you i haven't
been in a treehouse for a month i wish
but i have been brooding about it
and um
you know my instinct is i think is the
same as everyone else's you know let's
use the federal system
uh to
you know create zones of choice where
people can decide how they want to live
you know by moving there you know
certain states will have these rules
others will have another set of rules
commensurate with the desires of the
people they represent like that will
that be enough will that be enough as
they're always trying to give the
federal government more power in the
presidency
more power so that's the pro that's kind
of the problem
it's like
that's not their temperament at all so
you know i live in a super rural area
where it's basically 1985 and people
just they they don't spend a single
second worrying about the sex lives of
hipsters in brooklyn like this it's not
even a thing it's like they're
interested in brooklyn they'll go and
check it out but they're not their sex
lives aren't that great from what i
understand
well i know they're all involuntarily
celibate that's
my obsession no one's having sex
everyone's talking about sex no one's
doing it which is like so distressing to
me but anyway whole separate talk but
here's my point
in brooklyn there are people laying
awake at night really agitated on a
sincere level too they're not it's not
just performative worried that there are
people in my zip code who are like
maintaining these attitudes that are
unacceptable and must be stamped out so
it's like it's it's asymmetrical like
one side
is evangelical
wants to convert the other side or kill
them and the other side is like kind of
traditionally liberal like hey you do
your thing i'll do mine that's why i
live here you know we don't have a
police department in my town obviously
and
that's because no one can afford it of
course also no dentist because no one
can afford it but
it's also because
unless you're doing something really
outrageous like there's no need for the
police like the the i will say this i i
live in a state that votes kind of mixed
it's probably mostly democrat actually
but because it's sparsely populated and
huge
that
there really is this tolerance that i've
never seen anywhere else like they put
up in a small town and anyone who lives
in a small town can i think confirm this
because it's just it's true everywhere
they put up with levels of eccentricity
of like truly weird behavior
in a way that like liberals used to
dream about i mean there are people in
my town who are doing like totally weird
things
and people still see them as people
they're not reduced to their weirdest
perversion or something it's like no
he's like he's a good father
but he also exposes himself when the
train goes by like you know what i mean
and actually there literally was a
person like that in my town for real and
everybody would probably do something
about a guy like that but i get the
broader point no no but you're saying
it's like yeah but people here were so
tall that you see the whole person and i
feel like an internet world it's like oh
you said something mean about gays
15 years ago where you were insensitive
to black people by current standards
then like it's done you're it's over
like no more job for you
and i'm not defending being mean to any
group of course not i'm just saying
that people are super complicated and
they have good days and bad days and
virtuous qualities and very ugly
qualities and they're all mixed together
in people like that's that's who we are
but that's not acknowledged online
because people's statements are totally
disaggregated from the person
and that's not true in a small town you
have to deal with people like we only
have one store it's a gas station
everyone uses it every day so you see
people every day so there are people in
there probably vote for candidates i
hate or doing weird [ __ ] you know when
the lights are off but
i still know who they are
you know what i mean like i said there's
there's three dimensions there that's
actually a perfect segue and of course i
do want to i do want to talk about the
book too so i promise you we'll get
there but that's actually a perfect
segue to some of the tech stuff because
i think i think the first time i was on
your show which is a couple years ago
now and we did it we did it this way not
in person but online i was taking the
more libertarian approach on the big
tech stuff i was basically like and this
is probably three years ago and things
have now been exposed which is why i've
changed my opinion a bit but i was
basically like their private companies
let them do their thing we'll build
better things and all that now you know
i'm building stuff
but
at this point it seems to me and your
argument i think was a little more like
oh well there are anti-trust things
there's something government's got to do
i don't know exactly what but something
i've really come around to that because
to me at this point if we don't do
anything then then we're all anarchists
like if the government doesn't exist to
do something about how they're
manipulating us then what is the purpose
at any level um do you feel like you've
been pretty pretty right on it the
entire time and and where are you now at
this point because i i know you don't
love the administration it's like do you
want them to have the power to break up
these companies
well i haven't been right about anything
the whole time i mean my views are
constantly in flux my views are
utterly different and you know i have
the misfortune of having been on camera
for 25 years so like it's pretty easy to
prove that my views today are not what
they were they're not even close
and i'm not ashamed of that in the
slightest i think people who pay
attention change their minds when the
evidence changes our our conclusions
always ought to be evidence-based
and so i mean i was a libertarian i mean
i was a fellow at the cato institute
yeah unpaid
um it's hard to even believe that but
you know it's a different country and i
anyway so um my view currently is that
democracy is incompatible with this
level of concentrated power in the hands
of a few people like so the promise of
democracy is that everybody has power by
virtue of their citizenship we all have
a hand in choosing our rulers
and that's what keeps the society calm
because
you know you don't have to storm the
best deal or
hurt anybody because you know in two
years or four years or six years you
have a chance a meaningful chance if you
get your neighbors involved to make a
change
if people start to understand or believe
that they don't have that power they go
crazy you know they become really really
radical that abets radicalism and the
tech
power is so overwhelming i mean all
information in english flows through one
portal google
that i mean google literally and i'm not
saying this is a partisan at all just
like if somebody cares about democracy
prevented the trump campaign from
raising money with its gmail lists in
the last weeks of the campaign i i don't
think that was ever reported the trump
campaign was so stupid they never said
anything about it
but someone told me and i verified
that's true
so like you don't have to believe you
know nutcake sydney powell
to think you know that the voting
machines were rigged or whatever
that right there is rigging that's not a
free and fair election if one side can't
raise money what like that's never
happened before and
and i'm not even getting into the you
know
the rejiggering of search results which
are clearly designed
to produce propaganda rather than
what they promised which is to produce
the most popular results no
they've got a word they made up a word
for it it's unbiasing that's what they
do they unbias when they read it
it's so beyond and it's i mean first of
all it's driving people crazy it's
making people into like for real
conspiracy nuts because there actually
are conspiracies that we can prove for
the first time in my lifetime 52 years a
b
it's making
people radical because it has destroyed
their belief in the system
and c
it is
totally
incompatible with the system itself in
the in our system the the government
has to be the most powerful entity in
the country why because it's accountable
to voters so ultimately people were born
here who are citizens of this country
are supposed to be able to control it on
the big questions
if all of those decisions are made you
know if google's more powerful than the
federal government which it is
then
and google is not an american company
it's owned by shareholders from around
the world the sovereign wealth fund of
malaysia or whatever or china
then like who's in charge of the country
i mean it raises like really deep
questions like that so no you for our
own survival
we have to
we have to break it up teddy roosevelt
you know who really was always been my
favorite president when i was a kid i
loved teddy roosevelt because
he was such an extraordinary person he
actually hurt members of my family
um
you know what do you mean
well you know my mother's family was
had uh you know owned the sugar trust
and um
so he broke that up you know it was it
was a monopoly on sugar
and uh he have myers and he broke it up
and um you know there even when i was a
kid you know my great grandmother was
like who who was from that family was
like ted roosevelt bad
but i always thought he was a cool guy
and um
and so i liked him for those reasons now
as i age i realized what a wise man he
was he's just an extraordinary person he
believed in capitalism he believed in
democracy he was actually deeply
conservative he didn't want radical
change there was
massive global technological change
on his watch it was called the
industrial revolution and it reached
this kind of apex around 1900 1901 when
he became president
and it
unleashed all kinds of like
super volatile politics
and in fact it culminated in the
bolshevik revolution october 1917 which
enslaved half the world for 50 years so
like these technological changes have
effects that you know are really really
deep and roosevelt could see this it was
anarchism not communism at the time but
the anarchist movement was killing
people like all over the country in
chicago denver
you know butte montana new york city and
teddy roosevelt's like whoa whoa whoa we
need to return some of this power this
political power to voters
or else the country the systems will
collapse and we're going to get some
kind of dictatorship and he was totally
right and so the trust busting that he
engaged in was in fact
you know a last-ditch effort to save the
systems that he believed in capitalism
and democracy so you know clearly you
know that's what trump should have done
you know he wasn't serious enough to do
that unfortunately and and there were a
lot of other problems but i don't think
he could see i don't think trump fully
understood this right you know i don't
know i'll let historians figure it out
but we kind of missed a chance to make
these reforms and and i'm definitely
worried about it definitely
that's the that's the messed up part
because it's like i'm with you and then
it's like oh do you want to give the
biden administration the chance to do
this as if they won't make it worse by
the way i'm guessing you covered this on
your show but you know they took teddy
roosevelt's statue down at the museum of
natural history in new york city because
of something he said about native
americans and it's like the the planet
that these people live on i i don't live
on that planet i don't think i mean
teddy it i mean whatever i can't even
get into i i actually have assigned
in my barn a signed picture from teddy
roosevelt to my great grandfather over
over my sink
i really
i really buy it but look they don't know
anything is the bottom line teddy
roosevelt lived with indians teddy
roosevelt knew more about american
indians than any president in history
he'd literally live with them
um
no he wasn't a hater of america these
people never met an american indian i
mean the whole thing is they're children
and the thing about children i've got a
ton of them i can tell you i was one
once is they have this moral certainty
that's completely uninformed by
experience they don't know how [ __ ] up
they are personally because they've
never failed yes so it's very easy for a
child to make swift and severe moral
judgments about others
in the way that when you're 52 it's like
a little harder to judge because you
know how screwed up you are right
so this is why the camera rouge had 15
year old soldiers
and
that's the species of what we're seeing
take down teddy roosevelt he's white
okay
teddy roosevelt was like in a meaningful
way the most progressive president like
in the 100 year span in which he yeah
it's so stupid i can't deal with it all
right well all right we'll move on from
that one more thing and then and then
the book so i just want to talk about
the media landscape in general because
one of the things that i'm realizing now
that i'm back on the grid is i spend so
much of the time on my show just
cleaning up lies
just aoc said this it's a lie cnn said
this it's a lie kavanagh everything they
said was a lie covington kids all the
stuff that you've covered obviously and
i'm just a little curious uh first off
like how bad you think really like the
cnn msnbc new york times wapo machine is
on one hand but on the other hand just
like a little insider stuff on how you
guys go about doing your show on a daily
basis because i know your producers a
little bit and obviously i go on the
show and i find that you do the show in
a way where it's like you're almost
doing like uh it almost feels more like
a book than a tv show where it's like
each day you're doing something and then
you sort of pick up the next day and
pick up the next day and i'm trying to
do something similar here so that
everything doesn't feel like this
disconnected lunacy that that everyone
else in i'm just wondering a little bit
about like the nuts and bolts about how
you guys decide to do what you're going
to do
well i'm a writer so that's that's how i
think you know in terms of chapters and
you know serials this is a story i'm
giving you one installment today another
tomorrow it's just how my brain works
um but it's a practical matter you know
i wake up not too early i hope
and uh with my wife and four dogs i try
and sit outside for a minute get my head
together and then i write out a memo
every morning for the whole staff
on what i think the lead ought to be who
we should book and we've got a whole
pipeline of some unbelievable people who
work on the show just really really
smart i mean really smart and um
one of the people i talk to a lot so you
know we've had if i can brag the same
staff for five years i think we've lost
one person two people and it's pretty
big staff
um
and they're just they're all in they're
so clever they're so creative they're so
interesting but one of our our head tape
guys a guy called tom fox a guy's
freaking genius
and he really is my window into cable
news like the poor guy is very smart but
he watches all skateboards
so he's constantly texting he drinks a
lot i'm guessing
what he drinks a lot i'm guessing i i
don't he seems pretty sober but i mean
maybe he's on pills i don't know
but i like you know
i sit there with my you know stupid
glasses on on my phone and i'm looking
up i honestly can't believe that i
cannot believe they didn't say this
um so basically by like 11 30 in the
morning you know i've sketched out what
i think the show should be in my mind
it's always because again i was a
reporter and a
magazine writer i think in terms of the
lead you know what's
my editor used to say to me when i was
kid get in the lead like but what's the
lead like how do you open it up
you know what's the what's the theme
and i try to as just a as an exercise
that i've always
um
you know that i learned as a kid and
i've always used sum it up in a sentence
you know what's it about you know our
first segment usually goes 20 25 minutes
what's it about one sentence it's not
about eight things it's about one thing
how would you summarize it and that's a
really
helpful organizing principle
for putting it together
and then you know right around five
o'clock i try and take a sauna every day
because i think it's really important
right scandinavian i'm true to my people
and uh i think about it in the sauna
then i go out i think about it more and
then i sit down around five have a cup
of coffee and i start writing
um the lead and so that's basically it
but
the media stuff is so shocking to me
because i you know i worked at cnn for
years and i posted a couple shows there
several shows there and then i you know
i was the main anchor in msnbc for four
years i got fired
but you know i i still have a really
good friend who will remain nameless who
works here just a wonderful person
really good guy and i have a couple of
friends at cnn so
not a ton two but uh but anyway but i
know that world really really well
and the biggest surprise for me in one
sentence is how illiberal they are i
always imagine they're liberal networks
no no i'm liberal okay in the sense that
like i believe in the enlightenment and
i i believe in the bill of rights and i
think we do have rights
um
they are not liberals they are defenders
of the powerful which is the much graver
sin like you can have silly politics i
get it i've had silly politics maybe i
do now people make mistakes
but defending the billionaire class
blaming everything on like working-class
white people who are like you know
by far
the most shafted people in america look
at the suicide rate look at the death
rate i mean it's like it's measurable
but everything's their fault
it's insane cnn ran a piece today saying
white supremacists are applauding the
taliban and it's like
okay uh you know i don't even know what
they're talking about who are these
women but leaving that aside it's like
what are you really saying you're saying
the real problem with the withdrawal
from afghanistan was not terrible
decisions that the by administration
made of the pentagon made or that our
entire foreign policy establishment
bipartisan made for 20 years now the
real problem is some guy in alabama
who's got unauthorized views it's like
maybe you should stop attacking these
people because they are the weakest
people in our society and you're doing
it
in order to defend like the shittiest
people in our society but also the
richest and the most powerful you're the
praetorian guard for the most powerful
people like how can you live with
yourself i mean that that is so immoral
what do you think what do you think the
answer to that question is how do they
when you have to cover some idiotic
thing that stelter said or cuomo
just these these clown people when you
have to cover it right or don lemon as
you call them like what how do you think
they live with themselves at this point
when they just lie again and again and
we have the internet to expose the lies
if this isn't 20 years ago when you were
on cnn yeah and we couldn't expose
things we can expose it now and they
still do it well it's i guess i would
ask myself like i mean i lie
if i'm really cornered or something i
lie
i really try not to
i try never to lie on tv i just don't
you know i don't like lying i certainly
do it you know out of weakness or
whatever
but to systematically lie like that
without
asking yourself like why am i doing this
so if if these people ask themselves why
am i doing this you say well because i
want to protect
the system because i really believe in
the system okay who's running the system
you're you're lying to defend jeff bezos
like you're treating
you're treating bill gates like some
sort of moral leader like are you
kidding like how dare you do that how
dare you use your power
to protect and guard the powerful
even as you
clamped you know put your boot on the
neck of the weakest piece some some
catholic school kid from kentucky it's
like a parody are you kidding he's a
child
and you're using your power to
to crush him to wreck his life like that
that shocks me and i have to say there
have been many times in the 25 years
i've been in tv where i think
you know are we using this
like very substantial power that we have
to put pictures on the screen
to hurt
weak people
and i have done that inadvertently over
the years because i got carried away but
i really try not to and everyone who
works on our show
is very aware of like the most
basic rule which is don't piss down
don't attack people beneath you if
you're gonna you know take a punch make
sure it's upward someone who's rich or
stronger more powerful in charge of more
things than you are punch up
like that's just like a life rule and
people who punch down are the are the
worst they should have no power
whatsoever in my opinion right and the
irony is they're punching down while
pretending they're doing the opposite
which is the which is the grossest part
all right wait let's talk about the book
because i thought it was really
interesting so the book is basically a
collection of essays that you've written
over a couple decades over about 30
years and there's a line right in the
front that i thought was great actually
you say magazine journalism is worth
remembering and that you also then go on
to say that you know some of the stuff
in these pages you got right some of the
stuff you got wrong some of it could
have been written today and would be as
important some of it not but magazine
journalism is worth remembering i
thought that was a key line there
because it seems really dead right now
like when i read any of the things that
10 years ago were respectable the
atlantic just any other thing like
they're just all
terrible now
was there a moment that it shifted did
it was it as pure as maybe we all
thought it will be was at one point or
any of that
well the funny thing is is i grew up
thinking it was kind of shallow
my father was a man oh god then we're
really in trouble now i know so my
father was a magazine writer actually um
when i was born and
uh and a successful one and i remember
him saying to me in this sort of acid
way about a relative of ours who was
smart i said that person's smart
my father goes clever she reads
magazines
i'll never forget that
the lowest of the low right rather than
books like smart people deep people read
books because as my father always told
us there is value in the process of
reading a book you have to follow a
narrative for 300 pages you have to pay
attention to the same storyline
as it unfolds and develops and that's
really good training for your brain
because you see things longitudinally
and you understand that sometimes the
consequences of decisions aren't
apparent for a very long time like
that's you know long stories are good
but you know
i was a magazine writer and a book
author but really a magazine writer and
now that doesn't exist really and the
reason it doesn't exist is because
people can't read for 30 minutes at a
time because their brains have been so
totally changed by the iphone that they
don't even have the ability to do it
it's so amazing to me so that's part of
what's going on is the process of
staring at this tiny screen for
half your day or more
has changed the way
you
metabolize information
and i remember when twitter first came
out i was i made fun of it to everybody
i knew like 140 or whatever number
characters like that's the space with
which we have to express our the deepest
truths in american society like we're
kind of [ __ ] actually yeah
that's you know exactly because the
medium really matters yeah and
now it's like totally normal you know
the president united states was
communicating his thoughts on twitter
and now you know that's the forum
and so it's the medium itself it's not
simply that the business model went away
and that's all true of course was taken
over by the worst people yeah obviously
but it was that the american population
became incapable of consuming this media
because it was too
long oh that's so awful if you think
about it no
listen as a guy that just took a month
off the phone i get it i get it i'm more
patient now the i even when i opened up
twitter again on a quick scroll i was
like these people are all insane
even even though it had nothing to do
whether i agreed or disagreed it was
just like this short burst thought war
is just making us all crazy so you i
know and and you know the other thing is
it's all transmit that's the problem
with it and for me that's the thing that
i miss most especially now that i'm a
talk show host like and i don't
do any real reporting
um of the kind that i used to do is that
all i do is talk all i do is express my
views and that imperils your soul after
a pretty short period of time like it's
not good for you and if you know any
talk show host like they're unbearable
you know i can think of a couple i'm
trying to
you just cannot
talk to them because they don't listen
they only talk they're only on transmit
no receive and the beauty of writing
magazine stories was
part of the deal in fact the essence of
the deal was going out and listening to
people shutting up
blending in watching
taking in other people's experiences and
then thinking about them
and you have to have that in your life
or else you just become and men as they
age by the way become
less
capable of listening and more insistent
on talking all the time and i'm already
that way anyway i mean i just i can't
shut up
so for me it's really the job is really
dangerous like i could wind up
and i've told my wife i keep a 38 next
to my bed my whole life i always have a
little you know two inch barrels
especially whatever i was like
just take it head shot end it if i
become
like a lot of these people we both know
in our business
just end it before i humiliate myself in
front of the kids before they don't want
to you know be around me anymore because
i can't shut up and listen you know um
so that's i do miss that i really really
miss that just going out and listening
so you also lead in the book you talk a
little bit about how the business has
changed because it's not just our brains
have changed so that's changed you know
sort of long-form journalism uh but also
the way the the structures themselves
have changed and you juxtaposed the way
the the publishing world treated josh
hawley's book versus hunter biden's book
and i think it's a perfect example of
almost everything that's wrong with
things right now
yeah it was so distressing for me i mean
i the book is published by simon
schuster it's the second book in a row
i've written for them it's the last i
would ever write for them it's such a
disgusting company run by disgusting
people but i didn't fully appreciate
that i knew that i knew that the guy who
runs it this guy john carp was
dishonest and not super smart but you
know that goes for a lot of people in
our world
in jail you really feel tucker come on
open up
oh he's awful he's absolutely awful um
but i know you know whatever you do with
awful people i mean you know i i can be
awful so i get it i'm not as i'm not
that judgy in my personal life
but
in january right after you know january
7th simon schuster issues a statement
saying we're canceling josh hawley's
book because
he is an insurrectionist so i was like
josh holly he seems kind of
mild-mannered so i look into it and he
basically voted to
you know stop the certification the vote
let's figure out if the vote was fair
whatever
okay you can agree or disagree i wasn't
calling for anyone to do that in point
of fact just just so you know like
i'm not even sure i was for that but he
did it
democrats did the same thing after the
2016 election after 2004 like i i've
been watching like i know this
so i'm like what made josh hawley
special nothing really democrats were
mad at josh hawley so simon schuster
cancelled his book which had nothing to
do with wasana was on big tech actually
so i was like shocked by this you know
publishers have to be for free speech
they have to that's a prerequisite
they're the gatekeepers of our corporate
intellectual life
our common intellectual life and so they
have to allow for a dialogue a free
exchange of ideas and maybe on the way
out margins maybe they're not you know
reprinting mineconf every year get it
but like the strike zone has to be
really really wide it really does
and
and it always has been and so i was like
i was really shocked by this so i was i
was rabbit hunting in maine
it was it was like a blizzard and i'll
never forget i was in my truck driving
and i got so pissed i called john
carpenter and i was like did you just
cancel his book because
you don't like his vote he's like well i
said you're disgusting what you did is
totally disgusting and wrong and i feel
implicated in it because i owe you this
book
and i don't want to write a book for you
but i'm under contract to do it and
you're holding me to the concrete i just
want to get out of it oh no you must
write the book i said well if i'm going
to write the book i'm going to open it
with the story of what you did
and i want to interview you and that the
idiot you know editor and
so i did i interviewed them on zoom for
an hour and i took notes and i printed
the conversation in the intro to this
book and they come off as every bit as
shallow and dumb
and like completely unprincipled as you
would expect in your worst nightmare of
what new york publishing is like i was
really shocked by it
and it was just sad and so at that point
it kind of put them in a tough situation
they don't want to print attacks on them
of course
but they figured correctly that they
cancel a book about how they've canceled
other people's books
probably a pr nightmare so they had to
go through with it you know they hate me
more than they've ever hated anybody but
obviously i don't care
um but i just felt a moral obligation is
because they were sending me money to do
this book and i didn't want to be part
of it at all and i really did my best to
get out of doing this book they
threatened to sue me they really got up
in my face about it
and so i was like okay fine i'm going to
write a book about you and i did and i i
i dedicated it to john carp and what a
worm he is and i really mean that
so you juxtaposed that with with with
the hunter stuff and the hunter stuff
was a little bit different right the
publishing world and big tech and
everybody a little bit different when it
came to hunter hunter is illiterate like
i know hunter biden really well he was
right you talk about that yeah yeah yeah
and i always i mean i always liked him
and
you know i used to party way too much
and and i quit 19 years ago so i'm the
last person who's going to judge an
addiction
i still use nicotine product you know
every waking hour so you're not going to
catch me being like oh you're addicted
you know i i get it yeah
but and and there are a lot of things
about hunter i like and always did like
and i feel so bad for him he anyway it's
a very complicated story but i'm not
anti-hunter biden but pretending that
hunter biden can like write a book or
has something useful to say or even as
an audience is like insulting to me i
know the answers to all those questions
are no
so
they paid him millions of dollars what
are they doing they're paying off the
administration of course because they
see the the federal government as their
real audience they don't mind that they
lost all the money on the hunter biden
book they made a statement that the
people in charge
you know are on the same team as they
are and i just think that's so dark it's
unbelievable and just to be totally
clear
there are a lot of payoffs in american
life the society is increasingly corrupt
and of all the people who get payoffs it
doesn't 100 is not the worst person i
know i probably you know everyone's like
really you're defending hundred biden
you know there are a lot of bad people
and hunter bynes not a bad person he's
just screwed up you know whatever done a
lot of bad things
but uh so i wasn't mad that they gave
him the money i'm just mad that they
paid off
a political regime like that is not your
job if you're a publisher you're
supposed to be brave
um
by the way i mean the publishing world
was also giving what five million to now
disgraced former i didn't know until
yesterday former new york governor
andrew cuomo for a book in the middle of
a pandemic you missed all that i can't i
missed all that it was a good month man
it was a good month
you know what's so funny is i mean
you've been doing this for a long time
august was always like i haven't taken a
single day off in august
and that was always the time where you
know i would always go on a fishing trip
or whatever or you know go to europe or
juice because it's august nothing
happens we that was only hallway month
we make up stories
but
all of a sudden it's like you go away
for august and you missed a ton
yeah well actually speaking of that and
then we'll let's just do one more august
related thing then and then we'll we'll
get back to the book the the afghanistan
stuff obviously i have to ask you a
little bit about that because i'm just
catching up on it literally in the last
24 hours
it's sort of from my perspective
impossible to tell exactly what happened
from from a media perspective because it
seems like they really are trying to
figure out a way not to blame the
administration but this thing seems
like as bad a bungling as
could it could it have been worse at
this point like what could have made
this worse this exit and now everything
that's happening i don't i can't see it
and i say that as someone who was
passionately
passionately in favor of withdrawing
troops because i i didn't see the point
no one could ever explain what the
mission was and that's just a violation
of my most basic rule of life which is
know why you're doing something you know
what i mean yeah especially if people
are dying and you're spending trillions
to do it what is it and no one can
answer so i was totally pulling out
but to
in order of severity leave american
citizens behind
move
tens of thousands
of unvetted afghans who did not work for
the u.s military who aren't our allies
whose identities we don't know into
suburban america
and then three to leave behind 90
billion dollars worth of military
equipment an entire air force 360 000
automatic battle rifles heavy machine
guns blackhawks fixed-wing i mean it
it's the taliban now control the best
armed military of its size in the world
it's unimaginable
it's unbelievable and then then you
start learning and i felt i was pretty
well versed on afghan i mean i first
went over there in october
of 2001 because i was a working
journalist and
you know that was my job so i've sort of
paid attention to afghanistan for 20
years not not as deeply as i thought i
was however because we learned all these
things like is that really was that
really happening the president of
afghanistan
left the country without telling anyone
and some of his aides who were at lunch
got back to the office and he was gone
he was on a flight to tajikistan with
tens of millions of u.s currency
how did that happen who was this guy
turns out we installed as the president
of afghanistan a professor from johns
hopkins
who like is the last person i mean it
just tells you everything about our our
ruling class which is they only
talk to
believe trust promote people exactly
like them if you are
i don't think you speak dari or pashto
i'm assuming but if i said dave rubin
your job is to pick a leader of
afghanistan you'd probably pick
some pretty tough posh tune warlord type
who could make the provinces obey if you
wanted a central government right he
probably wouldn't have gone to john
hopkins how about that right
so then it turns out that this guy's
doll he's got two kids both of the
american passports one is a and i'm
quoting visual artist in brooklyn
and the other was the staff for pete
buddha judge's presidential campaign and
you're like wait a second afghanistan
the poorest country in the world on the
other side you know south asia other
side of the globe we pick a leader who
is exactly
like our leaders and that's how you know
that it's all about narcissism like it's
only about self-love self-worship like
these people are incompetent
because they're narcissists like they
can't imagine that anybody but a johns
hopkins professor of some like totally
douchey discipline too like social
science
he's not even like a math professor he's
not even a real professor and you made
him president of afghanistan because i
think it was i think it was lesbian
dance theory i'll have to i'll have to
check that but i think yeah
so but but how bad do you i mean
like how bad do you think this will be i
mean it seems to me this is almost the
type of thing if we had an honest media
that could actually topple an
administration like this this seems like
and now the phone call where biden
basically was in advance trying to cover
the whole thing up about how bad things
had gotten there like this seems
extraordinarily awful
yeah i mean i i think it's one of those
moments and there are you know usually
things change incrementally in a way
that's only barely perceptible and you
wake up and everything's different you
know 2015 the middle class became the
minority of the american population no
one really noticed
six years later it's like pretty obvious
okay that we live in brazil
this is one of those rare moments where
the pivot point is like right in your
face it's crisp it's dramatic it's on
television like you know that nothing
will be the same after this you're just
not exactly sure in what way it'll be
different but the obvious the obvious
effects of course were just a radical
diminishment of american power you know
it's pretty clear the united states
can't actually enforce its will even on
this stone each country
it can't make anybody do what it wants
them to do it won't protect people it
says it will protect a kid and protect
its own citizens because it doesn't even
try the people in charge are dumb they
don't know they're dumb they have no
actual skills they're totally unaware of
that like it's just it's ripped the mask
off
and i i'm not personally smart enough to
figure out all the ramifications of this
but they are absolutely profound and
you're going to see an acceleration of
trans already in progress which is like
none of the 340 million people who live
here really think that people in charge
have any clue what they're doing
nobody really believes the system is
real nobody actually thinks we live in a
representative democracy nobody really
believes in american empire like it just
makes everybody totally cynical
totally atomized
there is no kind of
center of gravity in america like what
it
right this is bad man i think it's
really really bad is that the most
dangerous place that a country can be
that it only works if we believe that it
works and we sort of it feels like we're
in the show must go on version of
democracy like yes like oh it's just got
to go on because it's got to go on even
though the president probably has
dementia nobody's listening to anybody
we're we're unearthing and upending
everything we ever believed in but we
got to keep the show going
but everything works that way i mean
everything i mean there's a huge corpus
of literature on
you know the effective attitude on
health
you know there are there are cases not a
few many cases that are documented in
the medical literature of people who got
better because they like decided to
so like yeah you know mind over matter
that's a real thing how you feel about
something and the opposite is also true
anxiety can give you cancer like
terminal cancer so how you feel about
something
determines what that thing is
and in in the case of like a huge
incredibly complex project like running
a country this big
it's determinative it makes all the
difference like if people believe it and
it works if they don't it doesn't
and i'm just amazed there are a lot of
reasons why no one believes in the
system anymore but i'm just amazed by
the recklessness of a ruling class that
sets out intentionally to destroy say
patriotism
and then what do you replace it with
right we haven't replaced it with
anything so like we kneel for the anthem
okay what's your idea you know we don't
have a racial majority a religious
majority increasingly not even a
meaningful linguistic majority like what
is it that
holds the country together what do we
all have in common you know countries
don't hang together by accident
you know centrifugal force is a is a
physics principle like it breaks apart
unless there's a reason for it to hold
together period
so what's ours
and the idea that they would
systematically go through and like
destroy the the last remaining
connective tissue between
hundreds of millions of americans
professional sports well we're all into
football not anymore anymore that's a
political category now you know we're
all we all believe in the military not
anymore they're lecturing us about white
rage oh [ __ ] i'm white i guess i'm
excluded from this i mean like
who thought of this this is the single
craziest thing our ruling class has done
has been thematic
and the theme is destroy the connection
between americans
it's so interesting you're saying that
because since i just caught up on the
afghanistan thing as i'm trying to piece
it all together in a short amount of
time it feels to be almost like it's
intentionally horrible
like if you were intentionally trying to
not only destroy afghanistan but destroy
our credibility make us look like fools
make it look like no one's in charge
could you do it any better than you did
no no you couldn't it actually just it
breaks it breaks my heart and
you know i i don't know the answer and
i've asked a lot of really smart people
who know you know much wrote about how
the military works that i do and some of
them have recently been in afghanistan
um i probably asked five or six people
like that everyone i know like that in
the last week
this looks intentional to me this looks
like vandalism this doesn't look like an
accident
and
all of them have said you know i'm not
sure but i think they really are that
dumb
gosh
that's even scarier yeah well it is
scarier but but you also think like
motive may not even matter as much as
effect i mean
the message of course to china and i
mean everybody i know had the same i
wish you had been you were in
you know in your tree house when this
happened but the moment that kabul fell
i must have gotten five texts from smart
people i know who had the exact same
reaction which is man if i lived in
taipei i'd be i'd be offshoring my money
right now and buying a condo in santa
monica like everybody had the same
reaction
taiwan is just screwed and i think
that's true
um but
that's just a small piece
of the effect of this i mean rarely do
empires short of like full defeat in a
war
and as abruptly as ours just did like
we're done so what does that mean for us
i mean in some ways
i never thought we were served by the
american empire especially i don't know
how much we've gotten out of puerto rico
and guam and afghanistan and all these
other colonies that we call other things
but our colonies
um
you know i don't think it's been good
for us actually
but it has been
i would say on par good for the world
and i don't really know if you can be as
powerful as we are or thought we were
without having an empire is that even
possible i don't know maybe empire is
just an inevitable
stage once you get as rich as we have i
you know i these are all too deep for me
but i do know we're about to see massive
change
yeah and then there's the you know rome
was an empire too all right let's i know
you got to get back to that little you
know highest rated cable whatever thing
you got there tonight but i want to give
you one chance to do is there one
particular essay in here that you think
would be like particularly poignant that
we could just hit on for just a couple
minutes well there's only one poignant
essay in there and and it was it's the
last one in the book and it was a piece
i i've gone to this well i'll just say
it i live there now um
the same house my whole life in maine
and um and my kids my four kids grew up
there and maybe 20 years a little over
20 years ago
every september we'd go back to
washington we spent the whole summer
there and uh and of course still do and
uh but i you know put all the kids in
the truck and drive them home with the
dogs and it was always very sad you know
it was always
sad summer's over you know and one year
i wrote an essay about it um probably
around 2000
about how
nothing in maine ever changes like it's
the house that i grew up in that my kids
grew up in
and you know nothing changes like there
are things on the shelf that i put there
in fifth grade you know i mean it's just
like it doesn't change but we change
and against its unchanging
nature we see our own changes
and um it was funny just this morning so
i write about in there a workshop a shed
that we have it's been built in the
1890s and it's just like it was a cold
shed it has a workshop because things
break and i fix them or whatever and
their
shelves along one wall and my kids
when they were really little my oldest
is almost 27 they would put like little
things that they found weird colored
rocks or like a rusty anchor they found
at the bottom of the water or whatever
you know broken fishing lures
and they put them there as children that
this was their treasure
and this morning i was in there
fixing a line a rope from a boat melting
the ends of nylon boatline and i looked
over and there's a rusty anchor that my
almost 27 year old daughter put there
when she was like 5.
it'll be there you know when i'm gone
and it'll probably be there her
grandchildren will see it i don't know
there's something it's funny how much we
change without perceiving it but to have
one constant in your life
against which you can measure that
changes is really interesting and sad
tucker i think you've proven the
impossible that guys on cable news are
also human beings it's wild
i'm trying man it's not easy
we're gonna link to the book down below
of course and uh i hope i get to see and
not through these pipes sometime soon
although i suspect i'm gonna have to
make it out to maine before you make it
out to la
that's definitely true
see you man thank you i appreciate it if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell